- LANDO! WHAT?
OH, SNAP!
YO, LANDO!
YO, LANDO CALRISSIAN!
- OH, HI.
YEAH, THAT'S ME.
- OH...DUDE!
LANDO!
YO! YO, YOU STRAIGHT UP RUNNING
CLOUD CITY RIGHT NOW, DOG!
- [chuckles]
- THAT'S YOU, MAN!
YOU OUT THERE JUST--
[imitates ship engine whirring,
laser blasts]
SWOOSH!
- WELL, YOU KNOW,
I-I DO MY BEST.
- ZEEF, MAN. ZEEF HOWDO.
BIG FAN, BIG FAN.
- WELL, ZEEF, IT'S REAL NICE
TO MAKE YOUR ACQUAINTANCE.
- STRAIGHT UP, THOUGH--
STRAIGHT UP, MAN.
YOU AN INSPIRATION
TO ALL OF US, MAN.
YOU INSP--YOU'RE THE REASON
I'M OUT HERE IN CLOUD CITY, DOG.
MAN, I AIN'T EVEN JOKING, MAN.
- THAT'S NICE.
- BUT, YO, IDEALLY, THOUGH?
- YEAH?
- IDEALLY--
ON AN IDEAL SITUATION,
I WOULD BE DOING
LIKE WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
I'D BE UP THERE, LIKE,
IN THE HIGH CHAMBERS
OF CLOUD CITY, DOG.
- WELL, ZEEF,
IT'S NICE TO MEET YOU.
- YO, RIGHT ON, MAN,
'CAUSE THEY GOT ME
IN THE CARBONITE ROOM
RIGHT NOW, SON.
THAT'S BULL[bleep], RIGHT?
THEY GOT ME WORKING
WITH SOME PIG DUDES AND WHATNOT.
YO, I AIN'T NO PIG,
YOU KNOW?
AND YOU EVER NOTICE, MAN,
THERE AIN'T A LOT OF BROTHERS
OUT HERE, MAN, IN SPACE.
RIGHT? IT'S LIKE THEY'RE
TRYING TO KEEP US DOWN, MAN.
- YOU KNOW, I-I DON'T THINK
THAT IT'S THE POLICY.
I JUST THINK IT'S
REALLY, REALLY DIFFICULT
TO GET TO THIS LEVEL.
YOU'VE GOT TO UNDERSTAND
THE POLITICS OF THE EMPIRE
AND, AT THE SAME TIME,
ALL THE MOTIVATIONS
OF THE REBEL ALLIANCE.
- ALL THAT, MAN, ALL THAT.
- YOU'VE GOT--
- ALL THAT, ALL THAT,
ALL THAT, ALL THAT, ALL THAT.
BUT IDEALLY, THOUGH, MAN?
IDEALLY, WHAT I'M TALKING
ABOUT IS, LIKE, ME AND YOU--
WE SHOULD, LIKE, DO SOMETHING
TOGETHER, THOUGH, MAN,
'CAUSE IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT,
YO, WHEN I WAS YOUNGER, MAN,
I USED TO FLY THOSE LANDSPEEDERS
ALL THE TIME.
MY FRIENDS WAS LIKE,
"MAN, YOU SHOULD BE PILOTING
ONE OF THE X-WINGS,"
RIGHT?
AND SO THAT'S,
LIKE, DISAPPOINTING, MAN,
'CAUSE I GOT HERE,
AND THEY JUST HAD ME, LIKE,
CLEANING UP THE R2 UNITS
AFTER THE X-WINGS COME IN.
- ZEEF, I GOT TO GO.
YOU SHOULD PROB--
OH, NO.
- MAN, I'M SAYING, MAN,
HOW DO WE CONTACT ONE ANOTHER?
'CAUSE THAT'S
THE MOST IMPORTANT THING--
THAT WE CONTACT ONE ANOTHER,
'CAUSE, YO, LOOK, MAN,
IDEALLY, THOUGH?
IDEALLY THOUGH?
I WOULD GET TO FLY, SOMEHOW,
LIKE, THE MILLENNIUM FALCON.
LIKE, THAT WOULD BE COOL.
[device beeps]
AND, YO, LET ME GET YOU MY--
LIKE, MY CONT--
I GOT MY CARD
IN HERE SOMEWHERE.
[beeping]
MAN, I'M JUST TRYING
TO FIND THIS, LIKE,
POCKET RIGHT HERE,
'CAUSE THESE--
SOMETIMES, THESE SUITS,
THEY DON'T GOT NO POCKETS.
- YOU KNOW WHAT, ZEEF?
JUST GIVE YOUR INFORMATION
TO LOBOT HERE,
AND WE'LL BE IN TOUCH.
- LOBOT?
MAN, I SEE HOW IT IS.
I GOT TO TALK TO YOUR MANDROID
RIGHT NOW?
MAN, [bleep] YOU, [bleep]!
LITTLE WHITE-ASS HAIR!
WHY YOU WEARING A CAPE,
THOUGH, HUH?
WHERE YOU GOING,
THE ICE PLANET HOTH?
- [chuckles]
OUTRAGEOUS.